The previous segment of this
lecture examined the rules
that determine which
among competing claimants
is the author of a copyrighted work.
But occasionally, more
than one person can
claim to have contributed enough
to a work to be called an author
and thus, to share in the copyright.
The legal condition that
arises under such circumstances
is known as joint authorship.
It doesn't happen very often, for
reasons we'll discuss in a minute.
But when it occurs, it has
some important effects.
Each author in such cases is said
to be an owner of the whole work,
not just the part he or she contributed.
Each is free to use the work
or to license others to use it.
If one of the joint authors licenses it
unilaterally and collects license fees,
he or she must give the other joint
author or authors appropriate shares.
If he fails to do so, he's
subject to a suit for accounting.
How much of the revenue does he have
to give the other joint authors?
The presumption is that each one
is entitled to an equal share.
This is true even if their contributions
have clearly been unequal in amount.
However, this presumption
of equality can
be overridden by an agreement
among the joint authors.
When a joint author dies, his or her
interest passes to his or her heirs,
not to the other joint authors.
In this respect, joint
authorship, in copyright law,
works like a tenancy in common and real
property law, not like a joint tenancy.
The main difference between those two
legal forms is that the latter carries
with it a right of survivorship
while the former doesn't.
In sum, joint authorship has many
important legal implications.
So when and how does
this situation arise?
The answer with respect to US
law is that a person claiming
to be a joint author has
to show both of two things.
First, he must show that each of
the people, including himself,
that he asserts share in the copyright
made a copyrightable contribution
to the final work at issue.
Second, he must show that
all of these contributors
intended that their
various contributions be
merged into a unitary whole.
These requirements are usually
construed quite strictly by the courts.
The net result is that most people who
seek the status of joint author fail.
Here's a case that illustrates the
impediments that the law places
in the path of those who
would be joint authors.
Rent is one of the most famous and
successful musicals of all time.
It was set in and first performed in New
York City, but productions of the play
have since been staged
throughout the world.
Here, for example, is a poster
from a production in Oregon
and one from Jakarta.
My daughters used to sing most
of the songs from the play
when riding in the backseat of my car.
The plot of Rent is loosely
based on Puccini's opera La
Boheme, which has long
been out of copyright.
It's based on Puccini's work in much the
same rough way that West Side Story is
based on Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet.
Set during a period when
AIDS was often fatal,
Rent examines the intertwined lives
of a group of young, poor artists
and musicians, many of them
living with the disease.
The genesis of the
musical is complicated
and those complications are the
source of the copyright dispute
that concerns us here.
The narrative is traced in the
slide you see on the screen.
In 1989, Billy Aronson and
composer Jonathan Larson
began to collaborate on an
adaptation of La Boheme.
In 1991, Aronson withdrew
from the collaboration.
They settled their respective rights
in the inchoate script amicably,
and Larson carried on with
the project by himself.
In 1992 and 1993, James Nicola, who was
then artistic director of the New York
Theater Workshop-- a small, nonprofit
theater in the East Village--
expressed enthusiasm about
the script, but Nicola
urged Larson to permit
the theater workshop
to hire a playwright or a book writer
who would help Larson improve the story
line and the narrative
structure of the play.
Larson refused, insisting that
he wanted to do it himself.
In 1994, Larson got a grant to
put on a short run of shows.
Nicola agreed to produce
them at the theater workshop
and Michael Greif directed them.
The reviews of this initial trial
production of Rent were positive,
but everyone agreed that the
play still needed lots of work.
Nicola again pressed
Larson to accept some help.
And finally in May of
1995, Larson acquiesced.
The theater workshop, not
Larson, hired Lynn Thomson--
a professor of advanced play
writing at New York University--
to serve as a dramaturg.
A dramaturg is someone who assists
in some way in the production
and development of plays.
The contract between the
theater workshop and Thomson
indicated that she would receive
a fee of $2,000 in return
for, quote, "providing dramaturgical
assistance and research
to the playwright and
director," close quote.
In the summer and fall of 1995, Thomson
and Larson worked closely together.
Thomson came to Larson's apartment
where they worked feverishly
to revise the script.
Typically, Larson sat at the
computer typing revisions
while Thomson made suggestions.
Many of the adjustments and
particular lines that she came up with
found their way into the final script.
This collaboration was highly
successful, at least gauging
by the final outcome.
The new script was thought
to entail a, quote,
"radical transformation of the show,"
close quote, and was widely celebrated.
The final dress rehearsal
was held on January 24, 1996.
Tragically, Larson died that
evening of an aortic aneurysm.
The legal effect of this
catastrophe is that his property,
including whatever copyright interests
he had acquired by that point,
passed to his heirs.
Thereafter, Nicola, Greif and Thomson
worked together to tune the script.
The off-Broadway production was highly
praised and it soon moved to Broadway.
And the rest is history.
As the play became ever more
commercially successful,
Thomson became ever more unhappy
with her paltry compensation
and with the absence of
any credit she received
on the title page of the production.
The Broadway producers agreed to
pay her an additional $10,000,
but she was still not satisfied.
She asked Larson's heirs for a
share of the author's royalties.
Those royalties were
originally payable to Larson
and were now flowing to the heirs.
The heirs offered her 1% as what
they described as a gift-- not enough
for Thomson, and negotiations collapsed.
Finally, Thomson brought a copyright
infringement suit against the heirs.
Her principal legal claim was
that her contributions to the play
were sufficient to render
her a joint author.
As such, she was entitled to a
share of the author's royalties.
She lost at trial and again on appeal.
Why?
It would seem from
this narrative that she
had contributed nontrivial amounts of
material to the content of the play
and thus deserved a fair amount
of credit for its success.
Nevertheless in the
court's judgment, she
had failed to demonstrate
the two conditions that
are essential to joint authorship.
As mentioned previously,
those two conditions
are first, that each of
the putative co-authors
have made independently copyrightable
contributions to the final work;
and second, that both intended
that their contributions be merged
into inseparable or interdependent
parts of a unitary whole.
The trial court and the Court of Appeals
found, or were willing to assume,
that the first requirement
had been satisfied.
Specifically, the trial
judge found that, quote,
"There are lines in Rent that
originated verbatim with Ms. Thomson.
I don't think they amount
to 9%, and certainly not 0%.
There's probably enough there that
it is not de minimis" close quote.
It was the second requirement
the tripped Thomson up.
The way that the Court of Appeals
construed that second requirement
was critical.
Two or more contributors
constitute joint authors
only if they all, quote, "fully
intended to be co-authors."
In other words, entertain in their
minds the concept of the joint authors.
If any one of them did not have that
intention when the work was created,
a joint authorship does not emerge.
Applying this standard, the
courts tried to ascertain
what had been the intention
of Larson and Thomson.
Thomson's intentions were clear enough.
She wanted to be a joint author.
But she had to show that
Larson also had that in mind.
This created an obvious problem.
Larson was dead.
So ascertaining his state of
mind would have been difficult.
More generally, letting the
legal outcome in such cases
turn on the entirely private subjective
intention of one of the parties
seems at best an awkward way
of resolving the disagreement,
because it would enable
one contributor--
by harboring a secret plan not to
create a joint authorship-- to defeat
the expectations of the others.
To address both of these
concerns, the court
looked for objective
manifestations of Larson's state
of mind made before his death.
Those manifestations, it
concluded, all suggested
that Larson did not
want to be a co-author.
For example, he exercised a veto.
In other words, he had final authority
over what lines went into the script.
Another indicator was that the
playbill, over which Larson had control,
described Larson himself
as the author/composer
and referred to Thomson
only as a dramaturg.
When Larson entered into contracts
with the theater workshop,
he referred to himself as
the author, and so forth.
These objective manifestations
of Larson's state of mind
were inconsistent, said the
courts, with an intention
to share authorship and thus,
fatal to Thomson's claim.
The approach adopted
by the Court of Appeals
in the Rent case-- which is now
the authoritative interpretation
of joint authorship in the highly
influential Second Circuit--
makes it very difficult for a
contributor to a collective work
to qualify as a joint author.
The reason is that no matter
how much he contributed,
his claims can be defeated if
any one of the other contributors
did not want to share authorship and
made that desire manifest in some way.
To be sure, if all of the
contributors to a venture
not only put independently
copyrightable creations into the pot,
but also think about
the legal status they
want to assume, decide to become
joint authors and say as much,
then they become joint authors.
But if anyone opts out, joint
authorship does not ensue.
Not all US courts handled this
issue in exactly the same way.
In particular, the approach adopted
by the equally influential Court
of Appeals for the Ninth Circuit
is somewhat different in emphasis,
but the net effect of the
Ninth Circuit's approach
is equally unfavorable to persons
who seek joint authorship.
Before considering possible
explanations for this hostility,
I need to finish the story of Rent.
In the end, Thomson was not
left entirely in the cold.
In a coda to its opinion,
the Court of Appeals
suggested that even though she
failed to qualify as a joint author,
she might conceivably be able to
assert an independent copyright
in the individual lines she
had contributed to the script.
If so, the play could
not be publicly performed
without either securing her permission
or purging the script of those lines.
Thomson had not raised this theory
at trial, and so the Court of Appeals
could not resolve it.
But the Court of Appeals implied that
she might initiate a second lawsuit
on this entirely different basis.
She of course did so,
whereupon Larson's heirs--
weary of this multi-year
fight-- settled the case.
So in the end, Thomson got some
money-- how much remained confidential.
And perhaps equally important to her,
she received credit, not as an author,
to be sure, but as a
dramaturg on the title
page of the playbill, which
she had not had previously.
But the outcome of this particular
story is not our main concern here.
The key issue for our
purposes is the very high bar
that the courts have set for parties
interested in joint authorship.
So why is the law so hostile to
the creation of joint authorship
arrangements?
One possible explanation is
that they are messy in the sense
that they can give rise to a
confusing pattern of entitlements
that are costly to unravel.
For example, what if one joint
author grants to a licensee
an exclusive right to exploit
the work in a particular way
or in a particular region?
The example that Melville Nimmer
gives is an exclusive license
to show a film in a particular city.
Then another joint author grants
an inconsistent, also ostensibly
exclusive, license to
a different licensee
to show the same film in the same city.
Who has what rights?
In the 2008 Sybersound case, which
involved a more idiosyncratic set
of facts, the Court of
Appeals for the Ninth Circuit
ruled that the first
licensee does not have
standing to assert its supposed
exclusivity because allowing
it to do so would, in effect, curtail
the privilege of the second, third,
and fourth joint authors.
That reasoning may have
some logical appeal,
but it creates a host
of practical problems.
The general point is that joint
authorship, by fragmenting ownership
of a copyright, can create
messy and hard to predict
patterns of legal rights.
It's better, many economists
argue, to keep the legal rights
over any given resource-- in this
case, a copyright-- consolidated
in a single person or legal entity.
In real property law, this
attitude underlies impediments
to the creation of
long-lasting servitudes,
meaning promises to use or not use land
in a particular way-- promises that
will bind not only the current
possessor of the land at issue,
but also his or her successors.
In copyright law, the
same attitude might
account for the
impediments the law creates
to the formation of joint authorships.
A quite different explanation
emphasizes not the imperative
of economic efficiency, but the
history of the culture and ideology
out of which copyright law has emerged.
This is an argument
has been developed most
richly by three historians
and copyright scholars--
Martha Woodmansee, Jaime
Boyle, and Peter Jaszi.
Those scholars point
out that copyright law
emerged at approximately the same time
that the movement or ideology commonly
known as Romanticism took
root first in European culture
and then in the culture of many other
countries, including the United States.
The scholars contend that there's a
causal connection between these two
developments-- in other words, that
copyright law was powered and shaped,
at least in part, by Romanticism.
One of many ways in which copyright
law bears the mark of Romanticism
is that the law, like Romanticism,
celebrates individual artists
and is skeptical of collaboration.
This argument, if
well-founded, has implications
that reach far beyond the rules
governing joint authorship,
so I'll describe it
in a bit more detail.
Woodmansee, Boyle, and Jaszi contend
that until the late 18th century
in Europe, writing was often,
in practice, done collectively
and neither popular nor elite
culture placed a high value
on the individual artist or author,
nor was innovation especially prized.
Rather, from the Middle Ages
through the Renaissance, quote,
"Writing derived its value and
authority from its affiliation
with the text that preceded it--
its derivation rather than deviation
from prior texts," close quote.
As an example of this
Romantic orientation,
Woodmansee points to the
career of Samuel Johnson.
Johnson, she observes, often
collaborated with other writers,
spent much of his time preparing
editions of other writers' works,
was not much interested
in claiming credit
for the ideas he provided
to other writers,
and often took material from
other writers without attribution.
Beginning in the mid 18th century in
both England and continental Europe,
there was a broad cultural shift away
from this set of attitudes toward one
that glorified individual
artistic genius.
A new Romantic ideal emerged-- a
person who breaks free of the past
and develops an entirely
new idea, or at least
reworks existing material
in an entirely new way.
This new ideal could be
found in and was popularized
by the work of Edward Young, Goethe,
Coleridge and above all, Wordsworth.
Here's a passage from an
1815 essay by Wordsworth
that distills this new notion.
"Of genius the only proof is, the act
of doing well what is worthy to be done,
and what was never done before.
Of genius and the fine arts,
the only infallible sign
is the widening of the
sphere of human sensibility,
for the delight, honor, and
benefit of human nature.
Genius is the introduction of a new
element into the intellectual universe;
or, if that be not allowed,
it is the application
of powers to objects on which
they had not before been exercised
or the employment of
them in such a manner as
to produce effects hitherto unknown."
This attitude was certainly
not limited to writing.
During this same period, individual
genius became the ideal in almost all
fields of artistic endeavour.
Closely connected to that ideal was the
image of an artist or author as aloof
from the grubby business of
commercial and industrial life.
The canonical image of
the creative process
became that of a solitary writer
or painter alone in the garret,
pouring out his soul on paper or canvas.
Another closely related
idea is that of art
for art's sake-- disconnected
from both utility and politics.
During the 19th century, this
collection of attitudes--
which together form the
heart of Romanticism--
was reinforced by the
broader ideological current
known as classical liberalism.
We touched on this topic
briefly in lecture number one.
Among the features of 19th
century classical liberalism
was a tendency to think of many
aspects of individual and social life
in terms of dichotomies--
sets of opposed polls.
Such dichotomies included public
versus private-- in other words,
government versus civil society-- self
versus other, facts versus values,
family versus market, and-- last
but not least-- art versus industry.
Copyright law was taking shape
during this same historical period.
It should not be
surprising that copyright
bears the imprint of these ideas.
At the most general level,
the steady expansion
during the 19th century of the exclusive
entitlements enjoyed by a copyright
owner is attributable, at least
in part, to the glorification
of artists and authors
central to Romanticism.
But many more specific doctrines in
copyright law also seem connected,
these scholars argue, to the
attitudes associated with Romanticism.
Here's one.
You'll recall from lecture number
three that the 19th century witnessed
an abstraction and extension of the
concept of the work to which copyright
attaches.
Take a novel, for example.
As late as the 1850s, the
protection enjoyed by a novel
was limited to its text--
the sequence of words
in which was originally captured.
This attitude underlay a judicial
ruling that a German translation
of Uncle Tom's Cabin did not infringe
Harriet Beecher Stowe's copyright
because generated an
entirely different text.
As Oren Bracha has shown, by
the end of the 19th century,
the thing to which copyright attached
was understood much more broadly.
Here's a quote from his work.
"At the dawn of the 20th century,
copyright's doctrinal terrain
came much closer to
the theoretical notion
of protecting an abstracted
intellectual essence,
irrespective of the many concrete
forms that it could take," close quote.
This shift echoes, at least loosely, the
transition from the idea of writer as
craftsman to the Romantic
idea of writer as genius.
A more intriguing possible
manifestation of the attitudes
associated with Romanticism
concerns the longstanding trouble
that copyright law
experienced when trying
to make sense of industrial design.
As we saw-- again, in lecture number
three-- at least in the United States,
the relevant rule is
that a useful article
enjoys copyright protection
only if-- and only
to the extent that-- its
aesthetic dimensions are
separable from its
functional dimensions.
That doctrine of conceptual separability
is notoriously difficult to apply.
Keith Aoki, a brilliant
copyright scholar
who tragically died
prematurely, suggested
that the roots of that
fraught doctrine lie
in the dichotomy
between art and industry
that is characteristic
of Romanticism and was
reinforced by classical liberalism.
We return, finally, to the
topic of this lecture segment.
The possible connection between the
rules governing joint authorship
and Romanticism is
probably by now obvious.
Romanticism celebrates the
individual artistic genius.
It would not be surprising that the
legislators and judges who in the 19th
and earliest 20th centuries
shaped copyright law
should seek to confer the status and
economic privileges of authorship
upon a single person and should
be reluctant to acknowledge
the degree to which authors
frequently depend not just
upon assistants who execute their
orders-- as in the Titanic case--
but more importantly, upon collaborators
who contribute meaningfully
to the content of their
works and thus, arguably,
deserve some share of the credit and
the associated legal recognition.
This contention-- as I say, pioneered
by Woodmansee, Boyle, and Yazsi--
that copyright laws in
Europe and the United States
has been influenced
in part by Romanticism
is lent credence by the contrasts
between the cultural and legal
traditions in those countries and the
cultural and legal tradition in China.
This contrast has been explored
most provocatively by my colleague
Bill Alford-- an expert on China
and its intellectual property laws,
in particular.
Alford's great book--
entitled, ironically,
To Steal a Book Is an Elegant
Offense-- contends, among other things,
that China's resistance to the
adoption of Western copyright law
is attributable in part to the
absence of a Romantic tradition
in Chinese culture.
While culture in Europe
and the United States
was being reshaped by
Romanticism, China, Alford argues,
remains steeped in the
Confucian tradition.
Confucianism included,
among many other things,
a radically different conception
of art and creativity.
Here's a passage from Alford's book,
summarizing this Confucian conception.
"The power of the past and its
consequences for possession
of the fruits of intellectual endeavour
are well captured in the passage
in the Analects in which
Confucius indicates, quote,
'The master--'" in other
words, Confucius himself--
"'said "I transmit rather than create.
I believe in and love the
ancients,"' close quote.
The essence of human
understanding had long since
been discerned by those had gone before
and in particular by the sage rulers
collectively referred
to as the ancients, who
lived in a distant,
idealized golden age.
To avail themselves
of the understanding,
in order to guide their own
behavior, subsequent generations
had to interact with the past in
a sufficiently thorough manner
so as to be able to transmit it.
Yet, as Confucius demonstrated in
undertaking to edit the classics
and to comment on them in the
Analects, transmission-- far from being
a passive endeavor-- entailed
selection and adaptation if it
was to be meaningful to oneself, one's
contemporaries, and one's successors.
The sense of the past's
compelling pertinence,
and of intellectual endeavour as the
medium through which interaction with
and transmission of it was possible,
permeated virtually all facets
of Chinese civilization.
As the noted scholar of Chinese
literature, Stephen Owen, has observed,
'In the Chinese literary tradition,
the experience of the past roughly
corresponds to and carries the same
force as the attention to meaning
or truth in the Western tradition.'
Thus in classical Chinese literature,
the past survives and warrants
consideration not merely as an obvious
foil for contemporary activity,
but more important, because, quote,
'the Confucian imperative insists
that in encountering the ancients,
we ourselves must be changed, for
we discover in the ancients not mere
means, but the embodiment
of values,' close quote."
It should not be surprising that
a country influenced heavily
by this vision should have been
reluctant to adopt a copyright
system centered on the image of
an individual artistic genius.
And indeed, vestiges of that
resistance continue in China today.
The line of scholarship
I've been discussing
has an important critical dimension.
Thus far, I've been emphasizing
its explanatory side.
If these scholars are correct,
the impact of Romanticism
helps us understand how
and why copyright law has
assumed its current form.
But these scholars also contend
that the law as currently configured
is misguided-- even perverse.
The image of author or artist
as individual creative genius
was rarely accurate, they
argue, even during its heyday.
Since the 19th century,
these scholars contend,
it's become ever less
realistic as an account
of how most copyrighted
works are in fact generated.
The way in which software is
commonly produced, for example,
bears little resemblance to the image
of the painter alone in the attic.
The law, these scholars
argue, clings stubbornly
to an increasingly outmoded
vision of creativity
whose inaccuracy causes both
unfairness and misaligned incentives.
Not all intellectual property
scholars are persuaded by this thesis.
For example, Mark Lemley-- a leading
intellectual property scholar now
teaching at Stanford-- argues that many
important features of modern copyright
law cannot plausibly be traced to
Romanticism and instead are best
understood as efforts to advance
the kind of utilitarian objectives I
discussed in the previous lecture.
One such feature is the
work for hire doctrine
to which we'll return
our attention shortly.
Providing an optimal
pattern of incentives
for the creation and dissemination
of innovations-- that,
Lemley argues, is what copyright law
is and should be primarily about, not
celebrating individual artistic genius.
This is an important debate.
It will arise in various
other doctrinal contexts
we'll examine later in
this lecture series.
By the end of the course,
I hope you're in a position
to make your own judgments
concerning the nature
and strength of the relationship
between the Romantic cultural movement
and copyright.